and the UK government has announced all
British diplomats and their families
have been evacuated from Sudan in what
it called a complex and Rapid operation
William Pati is a former British
ambassador to Sudan and joins us from
London sir as an ambassador in a country
like Sudan that can be volatile I assume
you always had contingency plans for
evacuations walk us through how that
works from the decision-making down to
the execution
well you have a you have a contingency
plan for evacuation but the very rarely
the plans very rarely um survive contact
with the Enemy and this is a particular
circumstances that wouldn't necessarily
have been foreseen that you'd have two
heavily armed forces fighting in the
streets of Khartoum
um most of when I was in Sudan the
evacuation plan was to go by roads in
the event of the airports being closed
go by roads to Port Sudan but that's a
long you know it's a long way and
fighting is also continuing in other
parts of the country so in those
circumstances your very little option
but to resort to a military evacuation
which is what's happened in this case
all right so you're saying when things
don't go according to plan you have to
throw away the plan and call in the
soldiers essentially
well in the soldiers indeed and then
this you have to adapt to whatever the
circumstances are the plan is you know
you can't cover every contingency and it
was clear from here that the embassies
were in the middle of a war zone uh that
they were being targeted normally
diplomatic missions can use can operate
uh with a degree of immunity but in this
in this conflict we saw attacks on the
EU Ambassador we saw tax on French and
Americans uh so the diplomats themselves
were unable to operate so uh had to be
evacuated and ironically were the
diplomats out of the country it's much
easier to put pressure on the parties
because you don't have hostages if you
like the difficulty now is how to get
British citizens out that's a much more
complex operation because they'll be
spread all over the place okay that was
going to be my next question what do you
do then because the embassy at least you
know we know where it's located it's
also to some degree 40 unified and
protected but the civilians who live in
various parts of the city how do you get
them out are we talking sending British
soldiers to various addresses throughout
Khartoum how does that work
I I don't yeah I don't think that's
practical you know to go and send brace
shoulders right to to knock on doors
around cartoon I mean what will happen
is what we what the British government
has done is they've asked all British
citizens who are still in Sudan to
register with the foreign office so we
know where they are so the foreign
office knows where they are what their
contact details are and the advice at
the moment is to stay put to stay
indoors fly low and the the focus now
will be on getting a much longer
ceasefire getting putting pressure on
the Sudanese military and the rapid
support forces to provide a much longer
period of ceasefire in which an
international uh evacuation could take
place and it's likely to be in concert
with uh with friends and allies like the
Americans the French the Saudis the
emiratis to to try and coordinate
efforts and then get agreement what you
would ideally get is agreement from both
the parties that foreign Nationals can
congregate somewhere in Khartoum make
their way there and then be evacuated by
Convoy to a safe place either an airport
or or the port but that takes a lot of
work and a lot of negotiation and a lot
of cooperation from two warring parties
who've shown themselves so far to be
difficult to reach agreement with that's
really interesting so you're saying the
best evacuation plan for foreigners
living across cartoon is no evacuation
for the moment until you can actually
work on making the the conditions for an
evacuation more uh more favorable
um what about what happens to the
Embassy once you've taken out and you've
evacuated your diplomatic staff I assume
it's not left completely empty a
diplomacy is always a sensitive place
um for the country that it belongs to
how do you protect it how do you handle
that
well the diplomats themselves will be
relocated to other nearby embassies so
they will continue to operate as our
Embassy to Sudan and they will continue
to provide expertise and their local
knowledge of of cartoon and the country
itself and our ambassador the British
Ambassador was all was in London on
holiday uh
or when the when the the conflict
started so he's already been in London
advising the foreign secretary and the
crisis center the other diplomats uh
will be relocated I suspect probably to
to maybe Saudi Arabia or Djibouti
somewhere near where they can continue
to assist with planning and with uh
making contact with British citizens
it's something they weren't able to do
while they were in Khartoum they'll be
better able to operate outside of
Khartoum and of course we'll be trying
to make contact at high levels with the
Sudanese military and the rapid support
forces along with other countries to try
and create the conditions so that our
citizens can leave in safety Ambassador
William Petey thank you for joining us
on the show today